from the first day of the  russian invasion  ukraine keeps telling our partners  that  if you don't close the airspace over  ukraine  you will be responsible  for ukrainian people's death too  russia uses missiles and bombs to kill  our people to target our infrastructure  this is a responsibility a duty moral  duty of the world  to help us  and there is  a will to provide  fighter jets to ukraine but there is a  problem with logistics  we have a confirmation  that there is an agreement between the  us and poland  about it but at the same time  we can hear that  they say that the proposal from poland  is not tentative  look we've got a war we don't have time  for all these mediation and  discussions  it's not a ping pong game  we're talking about people's lives  make this decision quickly  please send us the fighter jets